Thirteen of the 23 players on the squad are World Cup winners...
...including goalkeeper Manuel Neuer and star striker Thomas Muller.
The team will also see the return of Jerome Boateng in defense...
...and Arsenal's Mesut Özil in midfield.
Mario Gotze, who scored the World Cup winning goal,...
...has struggled for form in Bayern Munich...
...but seems to thrive on the international stage.
It's a great moment for me, coming back after a long injury,...
...scoring a goal playing in the national team in Munich.
It's nothing but good things.
It will be nothing but great things...
...should Super Mario replicate his World Cup form...
...all the way to the European Final.
But first, the group stages.
Germany are up against Ukraine, Northern Ireland and Poland.